- I am tall.
- I'm tall.
(suspenseful music plays)
- I am almost six foot
ten. I'm six foot nine.
- What?
- Wow.
- Oh, that's tall.
- Wow. And I'm six foot six.
- I'm six one.
- I'm six four.
- I'm six two.
- I'm six feet.
- I'm six four.
- Okay, so it seems like I'm the outlier.
- [All] Yeah. (all laughing)
- Does anyone here play sports at all?
- I do shot put and discus.
- Okay.
- And I've done wrestling in the past.
- From what I understand,
wrestlers are usually short and bulky.
- Oh, I do volleyball.
- I played basketball.
- I played football as a defensive end
and tight end for football.
- I actually played high
school and college shortstop.
- Dang. I don't play
any sports and- (laughs)
(all laughing)
- I did at swim and I did
Taekwondo for about eight years.
- I love tall swimmers.
- And what's your guys' ethnicity?
I'm part German and I'm half Mexican.
- Mostly German.
- African American and Guatemalan.
- Native American and I'm White.
- I'm half Filipino, half Caucasian.
- Oh, nice.
- Nice.
- Half Samoan, half White.
- I'm half Filipino, half White.
- Like mostly everyone
here is just going like,
"Yeah, I'm white."
And then it's just like a
couple of us that are like,
"Yeah, we're German"
- Nilpferd!
- Does any of you guys use
like those dating websites?
Do you guys like use your
actual height or like add a few?
- 'Cause he said he puts
a couple extra inches
on his dating profile and
I was like, "I'm six feet
and I'm the shortest of everyone
and I don't even do that."
- People lie all the time. Okay?
I'm tall, but I can be taller.
- I always do shorter.
- Some girls get really intimidated
when I put like six foot nine down.
- Well, yeah, that's a
little understandable though.
- How old are you guys? I'm 19.
- Wow.
- How tall are you like at 15?
- Where were you at like age 10?
- Were you dunking when you
were like in 10 years old?
- My great grandfather is seven six.
- Oh nice. Nice.
- Nice.
- How tall are like
parents and like siblings?
- My mom is five foot nine.
My dad's five foot 11.
- My mom's five eight. My dad's six foot.
- Do you guys know your
parents height by like-
(all laughing)
- Yes, yes, yes, I do.
- Just by standing next to
them, you know. You know.
- That's one of the first
questions I always get asked
is like, "Oh, how tall are your parents?"
And I'm just, I know right away.
- [Interviewer] One minute!
- All right.
- Go. Go fast.
- My mom's actually six
foot. My dad's pretty short.
He's five, like seven.
- Yeah. My dad's in my height
and my mom's only five foot four
but she's the Filipino one so.
- My dad is the White one.
He's six four and my mom's five eight.
- My dad's six four. My mom's
five five but she's Filipino.
So, it's pretty good for Filipino.
- I feel like your just
copying what I'm saying.
(all laughing)
- I said one inch higher,
there's a difference.
- Would you guys date a
girl shorter than you?
- 100%.
- What girl can I take
that's taller than me?
- Oh, Taller? No wait, I-
- He's like, no, not taller.
- Ah, taller. (interviewees laughing)
- Like women in the NBA?
- A girl who I was talking
to recently was six foot six.
- Oh wow.
- Wow.
- So, you're more
attracted to like taller?
- I am more attracted to tall women.
- He's for sure tall, guys.
- That's what I was saying.
I was like, "He's already
tall. He's not the short king."
- We're all kings, right?
- Yeah.
- But who's the short one? (bell rings)
(suspenseful music plays)
- [Interviewer] There was actually a tie.
Jesiah
and Carter.
- I mean I grew up in a tall family.
I played sports all my life.
Struggled with like finding
clothes that fit right
because I was always
super tall and skinny.
Couldn't really find a good car to drive
because all the cars that
didn't really fit in well.
And so that took forever to find.
Everyone would always walk up
and ask me like, "Oh hey
how did you get so tall?"
Or "Dang, you're so tall."
And I'm like, "Yeah, I am."
Like I don't know how to respond to you.
Or "Yeah, I'm tall. Okay?"
- I had a job as a day
stocker at a grocery store
and all these nice little like old ladies
would come up to me
and they'd make me like get
the water bottles for them
off the shelves that
are too tall for them.
Oh also, I don't say my full height
'cause I'm six four and a half
but I feel like that's cheating.
So, I just usually leave that to myself.
(interviewees giggles)
I feel like that's bragging
'cause like saying your six
nine is kind of bragging too.
- What?
(all laughing)
That's not brag-
- That was a straight shot at you.
- I'm rounding down too.
I'm actually almost six 10.
I just say six nine from the jokes.
(intense music plays)
(buzzer sounds)
- [Interviewer] If you
want to keep playing
because you think there's still
a short king among you guys
raise your hand on three.
Okay.
(all laughing)
- We're all like, "Us."
- [Interviewer] 2, 3.
- We all do?
- Yeah. (all laughing)
- So, like you were talking earlier about
like your leg length.
- Who's? Me?
- Yeah. What is your
guys' like shirt size too?
- And shoe size.
- And shoe size too.
- We know it's not you. Let's start here.
- Let's start with the freak.
I am tall to the point
where I have to duck under
a lot of door frames.
The doctor said I'm probably
gonna hit like 6'11", 7 foot
by the time I'm finished completely.
I wear a size 16 shoe.
- Wow. Yeah.
- I wear a four XLT. So, four XL tall.
My leg length is only like a 34, 32.
- I wear 11 and a half shoe. XL shirt.
- I wear a size 14 shoe.
I wear extra large shirts
and my pants are 34, 34.
- I'm 34, 32. I actually wear size 12.
I'm a runner so I'm really thin
so I can actually fit into large.
- I'm a 31 waist, 32 length.
I feel like I've been a
32 length for a while.
Like, I sprouted in like high school
and kind of stayed the
same height forever.
- You say you're six foot?
- Yes, six foot and then
my shoe size, I'm a 10.
- Dale was very fishy with his answers.
- The size 10 was a little too small.
- I thought he was lying about
that. He said wore size 10.
- I know you guys are probably thinking,
"Oh, 10. He is the short king."
I promise you I'm not.
I'm just, you guys are
just all very, very tall.
Yeah, I'm like averagely tall.
- Could've fooled me.
- What's up?
- Nothing.
- Everybody was talking
about, they were like,
"Oh, I'm a size 14."
And I was like, "They're
gonna think it's me
because I'm a size 10
and I was the smallest."
- Like I said, 36 by 36. Shoe size 14.
- I'm probably with the
heaviest one. I'm 375 pounds.
- I'm 235.
- Okay. How much do you weigh?
- 190.
- 6'2", 165. But I'm real thin.
- But if you run that's...
- I run marathons, so I mean I'm-
- I do not. What about Carter and Dale?
- I already said I'm 150.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh yeah, I'm 185.
- It's really iffy on this
like left side for me.
- Yeah, for me too.
- I think the right side-
- Carter, how tall are you?
- I'm sorry, six four.
- Oh, okay.
- Dale, you're six foot, right?
- Yeah.
I'm the shortest of all of you guys
but I'm not the short king
is what I'm trying to say.
- So, what are you saying that
you're actually just five 10?
("Dragon Ball Z" screaming)
- No, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait to that, wasn't there
someone over here in the middle
that said they add inches
on their dating profile?
- There was, it was-
- I am just six feet true.
Through and through. True.
- You said you add an inch
to your dating profile
as if you-
How tall are you again? Six one?
- Six one.
- But the thing is there's no,
you could get away with that.
- But why do you need to add
if you're already six one?
That's pretty tall to me.
- The reason why I add is
because in the real life I'm insecure so-
- What?
- Dude, I'm tall and I'm
insecure. That's because I'm ugly.
- Yeah, but like extra
inch isn't gonna like
it isn't gonna define like who you are.
- Say that to my girlfriend.
- He's deflecting.
- He was deflecting
and then he was deflecting back
and it was like I know
it's not the guy to my left
but I'm guessing it's probably Dale.
That's true. That's what I was gonna say.
I think Dales deflecting.
- Wait, I'm deflecting?
He's the one that
literally said unprovoked
that we adds inches.
- I said something the first
round, that you didn't say
until the second round.
- No, I brought it up the second round
'cause we were going
in order the last time.
(bell rings)
(techno music plays and clock ticking)
(buzzer sounds)
- Sorry, dude. Come on y'all.
- Sorry I'm so tall.
I feel like they voted for me
because I honestly don't
know why they voted for me.
- [Interviewer] So, if
you take a short king
is still among you guys
raise your hand on three.
1,
2,
3.
- What kind of cars did you guys drive?
- I don't actually drive.
I don't drive at all 'cause
I can't fit in a car.
I used to have an Audi
and then I had another growth spurt
and I was like, "Oh,
that's not happening."
- I also don't drive.
I get a friend to drive me
and it's always a convertible.
- I have a Kia Sorento. It's
got a lot of head space.
- Those Kias actually
do have good head space.
- They're amazing, it's like,
oh you guys can't see me,
but it's got like a dome at the top.
You got a lot of head space.
- Okay. How old are you?
I'm actually 40.
- You're 40 years old?
- I'm 40 years old. Kid you not.
Been married for 11 years to a
five foot four Filipino girl.
- Okay.
How old are you and the other
guy going down the line?
- 24.
- Last guy besides me?
- Oh, I am 22.
- All right, if the game
was old king, I would win.
(all laughing)
- You're both half Filipino, right?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- I have a lot of Filipino friends.
I don't think I ever met one
that's like over five like-.
- 'Cause we're half white.
- At least I'm half white. I don't know.
- Is it a race thing 'cause
I'm African American. Tall.
Does that count for anything?
(interviewees laughing)
- You said that you run
marathons, didn't you?
- I do.
- You're 40 years old.
You run marathons. You're-
- That's, now you're
just being ageist, dude.
- You're 160.
- There's a lot of old people
out there running marathons.
Trust me.
I do run but apparently
that wasn't believable.
- Carter, what was your
shirt size thing? Yeah.
You said the extra largest-
- Extra large or extra large tall. Yeah.
- Extra large, they're long enough,
but they're way too wide on me
and large aren't quite long enough
but they fit me around
my like torso, right?
Like I know you can't see me
but I'm wearing a fairly
baggy shirt right now.
- Carter and VJ.
Well, I feel like it's one of you two.
- Okay. (bell rings)
(exciting music plays)
(buzzer sounds)
- [Interviewer] Raise your
hand when I count three
if you want to keep playing.
But also remember every
incorrect person you voted out,
deducts from the cash prize.
1,
2,
3.
- I'm a little frustrated.
People wouldn't really listen to me.
- [Interviewer] If the box turns green,
the four people in the box have won
and you have voted the mole correctly.
If the box turns red, the
mole is still in here,
and wins the cash prize.
- Oh, that's nerveracking.
- I know.
(suspenseful music plays)
- Oh, my gosh.
(groovy music plays)
- Hey guys.
(interviewees sighing and laughing)
- Oh, this is embarrassing. God.
- Your answers were really good.
- I told you it was VJ.
- No, I was with you.
- I think he was quiet the first round
and I was like, "Uh?"
- I'm just glad there
was another Filipino guy
to bounce off of.
(group laughs)
- I was very surprised.
I think him sitting on
those bags made it harder.
I was like listening and I couldn't.
- I thought I was right a
hundred percent of the time.
You don't take things for
granted when you're tall so...
- Being Filipino, I'm average size,
so I don't think that I've
ever actually been short.
But being a short king,
you know, it's great.
Clothes are cheaper,
shoes are easier to find.
I can get into a Honda Civic just fine.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Oh, Snap. That's a lot of ones.
(VJ laughs)
I'm gonna go buy a pair
of size nine Nike Ducks.
That's what I'm gonna do with the money.
(groovy music plays)